資産デザイン研究所メール第七百三号、二千二十六年九月二十五日号です。
資産デザイン研究所メールは、資産運用に役立つ情報を個人投資家の皆さんにお届けしているウィークリーメールマガジンなんです。
金融資産だけじゃなくて、不動産をはじめとする実物資産など、幅広い投資対象を組み合わせていく「ハイブリッド投資」の具体的な方法を、できるかぎり客観的な視点でご紹介しています。
資産デザイン研究所や内藤忍の公式ブログ、そして内藤忍と株式会社資産デザイン研究所は、資産配分などの投資アドバイスはしますが、金融商品の勧誘や推奨といった投資助言業務は一切行っていません。
ここからは、メルマガ先行でご案内している、年内さいごの開催になるかもしれない「金利上昇下での不動産投資戦略セミナー」についてです。
このセミナーは、十二年続いて毎回好評の定番セミナーで、なんと十一月にも追加開催が決定しました。
今回は十名限定で東京ミッドタウン六本木で行います。
内容としては、金利上昇下での不動産投資について情報提供を行う予定です。
いまの環境下で失敗しない物件の選び方や、お金の借り方がわかります。
不動産投資未経験の方や初心者の方に特におすすめです。
詳しい内容やお申込みについては、ホームページからどうぞ。
続いて、「将来のお金の不安を解消したい方のための資産設計実践会セミナー＆説明会」についてです。
この資産設計実践会は、内藤忍が主宰し、開講から十二年目を迎えている会なんです。
インナーサークルの情報を活用して、個人投資家のみなさんのお金の不安を解消するコンテンツを提供しています。
金融資産だけでなく、国内外の不動産、不動産以外の実物資産、暗号資産や節税戦略まで幅広く学べるんです。
二百名近いメンバーが集まる投資家コミュニティに興味がある方は、まずセミナーと説明会にご参加いただくのがおすすめです。
こちらも詳しい内容や参加申し込みはホームページから受け付けています。
つづいて、今回のメールマガジンの内容構成をお伝えします。
一つめは、「資産デザインのすすめ」今週の気になるテーマについて。
二つめは、「本気でやる資産運用」セミナーや勉強会のお知らせです。
そして、三つめは「読者の質問コーナー」。
四つめは「内藤忍の白米ダイエット日記」。
五つめは「資産運用日記」。
最後に六つめ「内藤忍のつぶやき」になっています。
ここからは内藤忍公式ブログ「Shinobyʼs World」のコラムタイトル一覧についてです。
毎日更新している公式ブログの中で、前回のメールマガジン配信以降にアップされたコラムのご紹介です。
全文については公式ブログから読むことができます。
九月十九日は「海苔なしおにぎり」がコンビニで増えているという話題、
九月二十日は「やりたいことは先延ばしにしないほうが良い」、
九月二十一日は「札幌・函館・小樽だけが北海道ではない」、
九月二十二日は「キャンプはもしかしたら旅行より楽しいかもしれないと思う訳」、
九月二十三日は「投資家コミュニティに潜入した『スパイ』はなぜ失敗するのか」、
九月二十四日は「『承認欲求』という人生の罠」、
九月二十五日は「犬が引き起こす人間関係の摩擦」といった話題です。
そして、内藤忍のメディア出演や出版情報もあります。
マネックス証券の投資情報サイト「マネクリ」には毎月最新コラムが更新されています。
今回のタイトルは「これから住むべき場所はどう決める？
」となっています。
連載記事の一覧はマネクリのサイトから見ることができます。
さて、ここからは「資産デザインのすすめ」こんしゅうの気になるテーマについてです。
今週のテーマは、金利上昇で強くなるドル、弱くなる円についてです。
アメリカの長期金利は五パーセントを超えていて、日本も三パーセントを超えるレベルに上昇しています。
日米ともに政策金利も引き上げられているのに、それでもなぜドルは強くなって円は売られているんでしょうか。
アメリカでは根強い経済の底堅さやインフレ圧力が背景にあって、高い金利の環境が続いているんです。
財政赤字よりも経済の強さに注目が集まっているんですね。
いっぽう日本では、日銀が段階的な利上げに舵を切ったものの、絶対的な金利水準の差はどうしても大きく開いたままになっています。
低金利の円を売って利回りの高いドルを買う、いわゆるキャリートレードのインセンティブがずっと働き続けているので、これがドルの強さを支えているんです。
加えて、日本ではニーサなどを通じた国内個人資本の海外投資シフトや、エネルギー資源、デジタルサービスの輸入にともなう構造的な円売りじゅようも続いています。
つまり、金融面と実需の両方から円安圧力がかかっている状態なんです。
今後、日銀が追加で利上げをしたとしても、主要国と比べれば日本の金利水準の低さや、潜在成長率の伸び悩みなどが引き続き意識されやすい環境は変わりません。
ベッセント財務長官の円安に対するけん制コメントも短期的な効果にとどまりそうですし、日本政府が「責任ある積極財政」を続けている限り、円高に転換する可能性はかなり薄らいでいるように見えます。
一方で、一ドル＝百六十円を超える円安水準になると、為替市場での介入への警戒感も根強く残っていますし、こんごしばらくは為替マーケットが膠着状態になりそうです。
ここからは、「本気でやる資産運用」セミナーやイベントに関するご案内です。
先ほどご案内したメルマガ先行募集の年内最後の開催になるかもしれない不動産投資戦略セミナー、さらに、将来のお金の不安を解消したい方のための資産設計実践会セミナー＆説明会についてもご覧ください。
続いて、「読者の質問コーナー」に移ります。
読者の方からお寄せいただいたご質問に、私、内藤忍がお答えしています。
今回のご質問は、「賃貸管理会社から賃貸物件の現状回復、エアコンや給湯器などの無料交換の定額サービスを提案されましたが、利用する価値はあるのでしょうか？
」というものです。
ご質問ありがとうございます。
定額費用での修繕や原状回復サービスというのは、オーナーが毎月、保険料のように決まった金額を支払うことで、突発的な出費を抑えられるというメリットがあります。
入居者が退去すると、現状回復費用は必ずかかってきますし、エアコンや給湯器、レンジといった備品だけじゃなくて、シャワーヘッドやウォシュレットなど細かい修繕や交換も軽視できません。
こういった追加出費を気にしなくてよくなるのは、精神的なメリットがあります。
ただし、トータルコストとしては割高になることもあるので、利用するかどうかは慎重に判断する必要があるんです。
たとえば築年数が浅い物件だったり、長く同じ入居者が住んでいて退去費用がほとんどかからない場合は、その都度費用を払ったほうが総額を抑えられるケースもあります。
毎月支払いを続けているのに、実際の修繕や交換が発生しなければ、逆にトータルコストが高くなる可能性もあるんですよね。
しかし、築年数がある程度たっていて設備トラブルの頻度が高い物件や、退去費用がかさみやすい単身者向け物件などでは、定額サービスのメリットが大きい場合もあります。
また、見積もりの確認や業者の手配など、手間を省いて運用面の負担を軽減できるという点でも、費用以上の価値を感じる方も少なくありません。
結論としては、物件の築年数や想定入居期間をふまえて「その都度払い」や「自主的な積立」と、定額サービスのトータルコストを比較・検討して判断するのが良いでしょう。
ただし、最初から安定したキャッシュフローを得たい場合は、割高でもサービスを利用することで安心感が得られるという価値もあります。
この読者の質問コーナーでは、資産デザイン研究所のだいひょう取締役である私、内藤忍が、メールマガジン上でご質問にお答えしています。
それでは、次のコーナーに進みます。
続いては、「内藤忍の白米ダイエット日記」です。
今回の日記は、「浅草まで行く価値のあるディープな焼き肉」についてです。
焼肉は、わたしの好きな食べ物のひとつですが、銀座や六本木のような高級店よりも、上野や新橋にあるような大衆的で本格的な焼肉店の方が好みなんです。
インスタグラムで見つけた浅草の焼肉店へランチを食べに行ってみました。
電話してみると、名前も聞かれずにあっさり予約が取れました。
ところが、お店に行ってみたら「予約なしでは入れません」と言われてしまって、電話をしたと伝えたら、なぜか席を用意してくれました。
やっぱり予約は必要みたいです。
店内はとても大衆的な雰囲気ですが、無煙ロースターが設置されていて期待が高まります。
瓶ビールを頼んで、タン塩、カルビ、ハラミ、そしてキムチを注文しました。
すぐに出てきたキムチの味を食べてみて、「これは本格的な焼肉店だな」とすぐわかりました。
タン塩は絶妙な薄さでスライスされていて、歯ごたえが最高でした。
カルビやハラミも油っこくなくて、どんどん食べられます。
さいしょはカルビをタレで頼んだのですが、塩でも追加注文してみたんです。
そちらの方がさらに肉の旨みがダイレクトに伝わってきて、私は断然塩派ですね。
さらに追加でホルモンを注文してみましたが、これが人生でいちばん美味しいと言っても過言ではないほど素晴らしいホルモンでした。
全く臭みや筋っぽさもなく、これぞ焼肉の醍醐味だと感じた一品です。
さいごの締めにはテグタンクッパを頼んだのですが、油っこい感じがぜんぜんなくてとても優しい味。
食後感もとても爽やかでした。
接客はぶっきらぼうでしたが、常連さんたちとはずっと話し込んでいたので、地元密着のローカルなお店なんだと気づきました。
こんなに食べて飲んでも、一人当たり八千円足らず。
最近行った焼肉店の中で一番気に入ったお店でした。
さて、すぐまたリピートしそうです。
大福園は、東京都台東区浅草二丁目十三番六号にあります。
電話番号は、ゼロ三の三八四一の二七ゼロ五です。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。